welcome to this video playing yacht but
Grand Master Eric LeBron and the Italian
flag this time he gets around okay ups
let's see probably know benoni let's
play a bit on him yeah there are you can
play this the Benoni without the night
coming to 12 697 maybe he's trying that
white has ideas with h4m now it's not
really the kind of position you want
against him but it's a yeah it's hard to
play a player solidly saw something
something more strategically focused in
this in this opening okay at least with
with h4 h5 inserted it's difficult for
black to to play a 50 or any kind of
moves like that okay to eat two or 2g to
air to e2
yeah b5 maybe play this with tempeh
sorry for the noise someone is hammering
away here in my neighborhood okay f5 but
ok f5 is this a very double-edged
decision after f5 if it later takes
Knight takes my night is also heading
towards his six but not easy now he's
playing it anyway
our Pony on on d5 can also be a week
after the caption I mean
and not have to play takes if you place
after the caption night at five dots got
94 I am that's probably a very good
position for black feels very active
come on I really hate it if some noises
is distracting the game how do I play
it's not that's not very comfortable
here really this could be useful in
covering the third-ranked after the
problem is this is also very easy to
play for black he just as easy moves
while I don't have easy moves maybe I
should I don't know what to do here
early maybe I can play with f3 and just
capture with f2f porn yeah not a good
position
I would expect him to just take n play
Knight f5 and it's certainly a good
position for black yep okay i have i
have this but it's not helping a lot may
vary it's okay if there's nothing
terrible happening immediately to my
king I don't see it at the moment might
I also might have before
okay this is not so bad this position
okay I thought maybe just come in before
let's let's play a bit quicker be sure
to see for probably
yes this is possible is it threatening
something not not sure I are not at the
moment at least I don't see it wow
really night h form
ok
9h for teenage to my highest get this
insane position against the sky it's
amazing
I really don't manage to get something
want something quiet going I already
don't know why it's always stirring up
some trouble
then not 93 over it tough to play okay I
don't should be too was my original idea
I'm time morning which is no square only
this one still awfully messy position
Bishop c4 we're still good still good
black resigns well who is this game that
always tough this guy's really really a
superb dynamic player I final maybe I
really wasn't showing him around here
black is in good shape I father computer
gives white white is equal or even a
slight edge yeah I already felt that I'm
in trouble here but a comp is not
agreeable here I felt pretty okay again
does not look like it should be meted or
anything okay maybe 96's bet I am you
know 36 is better it's a very obvious
move across 96 but I thought I actually
thought I can play it at any time but
the difference is that now is he's
covering the square and this is not good
due to see takes before okay I should
take
and then play here with a with a big
edge okay interesting and here he could
have taken yeah the problem is that i
cannot recapture due to this that's a
big problem after here all of a sudden
I'm okay Bishop f4 is also good white is
winning now according to the comp 96 and
we should be Trey I played it played
this is okay rook g3 here but this keeps
at least plus two okay a blunder
champlin that the Queen he can play this
but check I have forgot to to stay stay
a rook up in the end okay I'm satisfy
this water was a good game for a change
thanks for watching